Hello everybody!
I'm finally gonna get to try out Helldive!
Okay, I'll say before I start, fuck that one guy in my chat
that was like, I'm gonna log into Helldive, you're so
dokeycat log in and get into a server.
Like, fuck you!
What is wrong with you?
Alright, so basically, I was like, I didn't realize...
like i've been in tutorial for like two hours now because i
was scared and then i was like asking chat i was like okay
guys because like when i got in it was like oh server is at
capacity um please try again later so like you know i've
never played hell divers before by the way never play hell
divers one i've never fucking tried out hell divers two
because i was like okay if i'm gonna play hell divers i want
to play it um on stream for the first time with you guys
because Like I had friends being like, yes, you want to play
hill divers?
I was like, no, I'm going to do this for my dragoons.
But then everyone was like, good luck getting in.
I was like, wait, what do you mean?
Good luck getting in.
So then I was like asking my chat.
Also, mom, thank you for the macheta soup.
Thank you.
Anyway, I apologize.
I'm a wizard.
Thank you for the soup chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, so I was like asking in my chat, I was like, hey,
guys.
So like, I'm in the tutorial.
Does this count?
And then so like, obviously, the first two people were like,
yeah, if you're in the tutorial right now, that means you're
in the server.
So I was like, sweet.
And then right after that, one guy, I swear, if that one guy
was correct, they're like, no, you're not in the server.
And I was like, oh.
And so I was just like, oh, no, wait a minute.
And then so then I was like, guys, please, I need to know.
Because like, being in a tutorial doesn't mean being in the
game.
Then we are so fucked.
Because like I could just finish the tutorial right down
before the stream.
So then people, one person was like, no, you're okay.
You're in the game.
And I wrote, like, nice.
And at the moment I wrote, nice.
One other guy was like, no, you're not.
So I was just like, okay, well, we're going to do it.
I swear to God, I feel like I'm going to crash.
Because, like, people were like, people were like, oh, yeah.
I mean, you could be in.
But, like, that doesn't stop you from crashing.
And I was like, wait.
me it doesn't stop you from oh no because apparently when
you crash obviously you'll have to go back in there again so
like i'm just like please please just at least at least let
me finish the tutorial also emilia thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you what do you call hell diver squad
composed of tyler dragoons free birds thank you again all
right so yeah um i just want to do my part and squash some
bugs for democracy So let's, let's get this started.
I, where am I?
All right, I've been like, I don't even remember what
happened because I've been like looking at this.
Earn your cape.
Check your map to, oh, I want a cape.
I want to be cool.
All right, time to find the one guy.
All right, here we go.
I've never played Hell Divers.
I'm actually going in blind.
I heard it's really, really fun though, friends.
All right, instructors, we see you.
you on the other side.
This is where all your tax dollars go to.
Honestly, I'm glad this is where all my tax dollars are
going to.
Alright.
Nice.
Let me see.
What about control?
Wait, what does control do then?
Alright.
have done this already before i got signed like before i'm
in the field you know i feel like showed up bugs why it was
man who was me god's image oh fast support thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh okay oh sorry i did it too
soon don't worry it'll be different oh okay it it okay okay
what do you mean okay all right all to dive in okay then
what after that what happens what do i do after that boom
what do you mean
i'm doing my part well thank you my magenta soup but okay
all right do i hold up i can't hold on i can't get off i oh
don't hold shift okay okay oh my fucking god that that's not
me i swear look it up oh my look at all these bodies that's
definitely not me panic thank you buddy akasupa thank you
thank you that's good that's good i won't that won't happen
in the real game.
E.
What?
How's the volume, by the way?
Grab a stim?
Where's the sim?
Oh, in front of me.
Okay, V.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, that wasn't me.
That was a different player.
You miss a bit load?
Okay, let me fix the volume real fast.
Boop.
I'll boost it up.
I don't know if Sound Guy's here today.
Let me, yeah, Sound Guy's not here.
I don't know actually if Sound Guy's here today.
Imagine that.
Oh, yes, if you didn't fucking run.
Everybody runs.
Oh my God.
No.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Okay, give me a sec.
This is way too low to sense.
All right.
Mouse sensitivity.
I don't... Okay, mouse scope set.
Okay, mouse... Why is it on 10!
Okay, mouse aim should definitely not be on 10.
Let me fix that real fast.
Okay, let me...
No, that's way too high.
The best part about being a gamer is that you're super anal
about...
You're super fucking anal when it comes to... We're gonna...
Oh, I have no bullets.
When it comes to sensitivity.
Step 1, grab a fistful of freedom.
Send the swarm something warm.
Step 2, penetrate and detonate.
Maximum some death for maximum damage.
Terminate the... Terminate the...
Termin... Headshot.
Nice.
More cheese, man.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
Alright.
Is that it?
Where are the ones that keep coming?
Oh, pick up the grenades!
Okay, sorry.
I keep forgetting that I can't read.
How do I throw?
G to throw a grenade.
Where do I throw?
In there?
Boop.
Nice.
Super destroyer.
Use a stratagem.
Just make sure you take a few steps back.
How do I do this?
Orbital.
W-A-S-D-2.
Oh!
Activating.
I'm doing it!
Where is it?
Oh, throw it!
I'm doing it!
For real this time!
Sorry, I keep forgetting to read.
Okay, now I got it.
It's okay, I'm doing it now.
I'm reading it.
I'm learning how to read, guys.
Look, you normally don't have to read in other FPS games.
Reading is a little hard.
How's the sound now?
Is it better?
Nice.
Yeah, it's just friends.
Yeah, see?
It's like, it's just life.
Use the reinforcement strategy to replace your fallen
comrades.
Voices a bit low?
Okay, don't worry, I got you guys.
Alright, that should be better.
Alright, control the whole strat again?
Oh, okay.
Activating, throw the stratage and ball.
That's right here.
Reinforce.
Whoa.
Greetings, soldier.
Are you doing your part?
If you don't do your part you know what's gonna happen just
like america all right what's this moving makes it hard
stand still for maximum but i don't want to stand still oh
whoops that's so easy what do i have to do to have toky
shoot me too Thank you for the Akasupa meme.
Thank you.
That it?
Oh, I need to throw it in.
I keep forgetting to throw it in.
Watch.
Middle mouse for first person?
It's not activating first.
I think you have to get out of tutorial first.
To activate first person.
Don't reload.
Oh, wait.
The mag is left of...
What?
Really?
That's so dumb.
I'm so used to reloading all the time.
I just activated here.
Oh, oh, oh, why would I ever...
I'm just gonna fortnight this.
I don't think I would...
This is actually disgusting.
I'm sorry.
This actually...
It looks fucking terrible.
It's not for me.
Hold the reload button.
You're... I mean, look at this.
It's so gross.
I need to hold R for...
Oh.
That's so interesting.
Alright, what is this?
Press 1.
1, 2, 3 to swap your support or your...
What's my support gun?
Okay.
What's this?
Okay, what's this?
Do I have everything?
Alright, here you go.
I mean, it's so gross.
I can just aim in third person because I'm not stupid.
This is not a competitive shit.
Okay, maybe if I'm sniping, I'll do this.
Whoa!
I might not be able to read, but I know I'm not that stupid.
Wait, is that it?
What do I do?
Retrieve the flag of Super Earth.
Oh my god.
What's the difference between?
regular earth and super earth more democracy I'm heading
over would I plant it here is this where super earth goes
okay no oh salute press B to salute sorry I pressed N oh
shit okay where's my other gun where's my there you easy if
I hold left oh I need a grenade I need a grenade oh I don't
need a grenade super earth has a cape thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you I know right I'm so fucking
good at this I can wear a cape I'm ready dragons I'm just
like you
I'm doing my part You're finally ready for the realest deal
of them all The galactic war Oh my god, it's it Democracy
Justice They're in your hands now Oh my god That one Okay,
to be fair If it really takes like less than like 15 minutes
to train a soldier To go to war I don't think like we're
winning this war
I get the cool cape though But guys I get a cool fucking
cape Yes, welcome to the tomato farm Welcome, welcome
Monster MV, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank
you Regular Earth was destroyed in the first game Along with
a bunch of super earths They just move on to a new world
They didn't call it super earth It's my noun smile
Oh god I like this If I feel the democracy right now I
really do feel the freedom
Oh shit Wait I can change my name oh shit okay wait wait i
want to be called wings wings of live of pride of science
i'm starlight of super wings of the people okay wait of war
of victory of twilight truth of the stars oh my god what do
we want wings of wings of law oh of oh yeah definitely not
honor
of authority no wait wait no of democracy wings of there was
one, there was one that actually what, where was it?
Destruction, there we go alright, doesn't matter whose side
gets destroyed, I'm here for it wings of destruction is that
me?
where's my Kate?
where, there's my Kate Hello.
I got in the server.
The democracy officer awaits you on the bridge.
Welcome to the Galactic War.
I'm doing my part.
Here you can see your friends' activities and join a
mission.
Alright.
Well, we're doing it solo.
We might try to queue like randoms and then have people yell
at me.
Also, is the sound a lot better now, guys?
sound so far my sound guys not here so i don't know may
liberty guide me what is orders uh have launch kill 60
enemies using it's okay now sound is good all right nice i
don't want it to be too loud that's that's really it for the
background go to the story bridge and use the okay
apparently i people were yelling me and was like do not
customize your character or you will crash so like don't
customize.
Alright.
Where are you?
Here at war.
You may cast your vote many times.
Alright.
Once on election day.
And another with every bullet buried in an enemy combatant.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Welcome to the Galactic War.
Here the community fights together against its common enemy.
The path to the barrier of planets is clear.
Upon each of them.
Faria planet engineers have begun construction of the term
Terminant control system a network of massive towers that
will cover each planet in the well-tested Neurotoxins known
as termicide soon our citizens will be able to rest easy
knowing their children Are safe from the flares of being
eaten alive but like are we the but did they live on the
planet First or did we live on the planet first doesn't
matter because they're the bad guys because They're not
about democracy.
Was that, is that it?
Am I, am I fitting in?
Am I?
Doesn't matter.
Because they're not about freedom and democracy.
We deserve that planet.
Hovering over a sector shows you how much of its super earth
has already been liberated.
Do not worry.
We will liberate you.
All operations contribute to pushing the enemies of Super
Earth back.
Select a sector to see what planets are currently playable.
All right.
Is this...
So this is...
This is our planet.
So I guess we just go here, right?
Depending on the war...
progress different planments will be available select a plan
to see what operations are available oh winter 100%
liberated already oh shit we gotta go in all right operation
is a collection okay we're gonna go liberate all right
spread democracy raise the super flags as an unassailable
beacon of liberty don't worry I'm coming in!
Wings of destruction is coming in!
To deliver freedom!
They definitely do not want me as a teammate, but it's too
bad.
Shots fire.
I... Oh, hey guys, I'm level one.
I'm just a little baby.
Do not worry!
Do not worry, you didn't need any help, but I'm coming in
anyway.
Joe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, Doki Bird.
You're manifesting destiny right now.
Nice, that's good to know.
Give me a sec.
I'm still figuring this out.
All right.
What do I?
S-O-S.
Wait, I didn't...
What's going on?
I didn't get to see what was going on.
on where am i i'm so confused um yes is this it i don't
worry i put push the talk am i ready
wait am i open mic no no i already changed it i already
changed it to push the talk I've made sure to change in the
push.
I'm so confused, but I think I'm ready
It's okay this man's level 21 there's no way I can fuck up
He's literally level 21.
We can do this.
We can spread democracy We can get carried
That's all that matters.
There's no way it's over.
We literally have a guy that's, first off, his name is
Chief.
Second off, he's level 21.
Like, how can I fuck up?
Confused and ready to do my part.
All right, here I am.
who's C3 oh we're what are we doing guard dog okay what are
you guys doing biggest thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you I'm I'm a little confused but I have who's the
who's like the strongest one who's the new type oh they're
calling in their weapons do I have any weapons sorry I don't
call in your m I don't need my mg I don't need my mg don't
worry I will do my part i can aim we don't need mgs i can
aim guys that is i can aim that's my part fuck i forgot not
to reload i need to remember not to reload don't worry here
i am i'm on baby difficulty then why are you guys saying
about these level 21s on baby difficulty huh what does that
say about them Who are they calling?
They're calling so many things.
I'm doing my part.
Oh, shit.
I can't see.
I'm doing it.
Don't worry.
They're the babysitters.
It's fine.
We're so good!
We're so good at this game!
Oh, I love my team.
I love my team.
For freedom and liberty!
Seeing isn't mandatory, soldier.
You do not need to see anything.
All you need to do is shoot.
So what do we do now, guys?
Where is this song playing from?
You know what?
I do feel the freedom right now.
I do feel this freedom.
Waiting.
Oh, I did salute the flag.
You're right.
We gotta wait for the flag.
Is this...
I feel so patriotic with everything going on.
Oh, is there bugs behind us?
There's bugs behind us.
us don't worry we can do this oh no what do I do I need a
machine gun nah glorious super earth yay wait someone die oh
my god what happened how did you die how the fuck did this
guy die what do we save him how do we get across did he step
on the mine did he step on the other baby i hope oh oh oh oh
i hope i don't step on the mine he ran over the mine See
guys, I'm not the baby here.
Guys, I wasn't the baby here.
I didn't step in any mines.
Freedom comes at a cost, Stokie.
You think it's gonna be easy?
Defend extraction zone.
I can do that.
Alright, use all your materials.
gun little baby man he died a hero you either die a hero or
you die or you live as a coward isn't that right guys
freedom is free that one guy thank you for super chat thank
you thank you we need more men at the creek for super earth
look I'm doing my part I'm shooting my gun is that nice Oh
my god, this is the- this has to be the easiest game of my
life.
Oh shit, I shouldn't have reloaded.
I- Oh my god, so easy.
And this game's been out for like a week and it's already
got first.
Shake my head.
Look, see, look at that.
So easy!
Orbital Inbound.
Wait, what?
Whoa!
Man down!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, I can't see!
I'm slowed!
We're good.
Fire and a hostile state clear on the field.
Oh, we're good.
Oh, I got a hostile state clear on the field.
Oh, we got clear landing zone.
See, I can listen.
This is it?
Where is it?
Oh my god, it's coming in.
It's coming in the freedom's coming in.
The baby!
Oh my god!
Please!
I'm a good person, I swear!
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm too scared, I'm going in, I'm too scared!
I'm scared he's gonna shoot me too!
I'm too scared!
I'm way too scared!
inside and don't want him to shoot me.
I don't...
He would...
He would be just to witness the murder.
That's a friendly fire.
This ore is hot.
Oh my god.
They smell gunpowder.
I smell democracy.
We are not the same.
Oh my god I witnessed a fucking murder I got so scared Oh my
god Yay glorious victory Oh yeah The other baby That could
have been me Guys I could have been the baby that got shot
Look at that first game first liberation
Marines we are leaving they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Yay It was a lesson
Woo Oh my god, this guy is like suit is like decked out
already.
I'm going back Where am I okay return to ship?
I unlocked what difficulty was I in if I unlocked easy?
Excuse me There's there's a difficulty below zero?
What difficulty was I in?
guys i unlocked easy i can't believe it guys i can't believe
i unlocked easy all right new customized no i'm i'm too
scared to customize after like that one chatter was like do
not customize how do i how do i move this i want to i want
to go do war how come it won't let me do war I want to leave
this group.
I don't want to leave this group.
I'm done playing with you.
Go back to my ship.
Whose ship is this?
Is this your ship?
Wait.
Return to ship alone.
Alright, see you guys.
I'm done playing with you guys.
Nice.
Oh, I'm in like cryo.
I just realized.
it's the other baby ship all right i'm done playing with
with with that team oh it was this go to ship manager to
acquire new strategy and upgrade your destroyer i can
upgrade my ship now and upgrade you can use this term to
manage your destroyer of what or which which your vessel is
on okay to use on initially destroyer only has access to a
limited category okay so like All I have is, like, baby shit
right now.
Ooh.
Anti- Okay, I want the rifle.
Oh, I don't have money.
All right, don't worry.
I can get carried by all the other ones.
By all the other level 20s.
How much money do I have?
Oh, my God.
I am so poor right now.
All right.
Here we go.
All right, don't worry.
We can keep on doing Democratic stuff.
Friendly fire is Good girl, thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you Alright, we gotta find a new place to
protect Quick play I wanna do quick play Wait, do I have a
medium now?
Guys!
I can do a medium!
Alright, reduced Okay, okay, who's 40 minutes, 40 minutes
Okay, can this guy carry me?
Can this guy How do I leave this planet?
Oh, okay, there we go.
Okay, I want to do medium.
Wait, no, I want to do easy.
I have to complete easy first?
Okay, don't worry.
I'm ready to liberate.
I need like...
Here.
Failed to jump.
No, please!
No!
Why did it fail and join?
Oh, this guy.
I finally destroy all the eggs.
No!
Please!
Let me do all the...
Oh, there we go.
Please.
I need as many people to spread freedom as possible.
Hey, guys.
Level 28!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
You want to click on basically what you can, which is going
to be machine gun shit.
Oh my god!
He's teaching her little baby!
He has a baby too!
Bro, he's like watching TV while playing right now.
Like his PC is like in his living room, I think.
I want to be like, what are you watching?
Yes.
Wait, what is a super...
What is a super citizen?
Well, I get, like, DMCA'd by this one guy watching on his
TV.
The one guy that's...
It's like, Scrubs has DMCA'd you, my friend.
Yeah, you can see his TV.
I'd look at him like this, dude.
This literally is just Starship's reverse.
Oh, my God.
Look at him.
The PODSD.
He's a PS5 gamer.
Which one?
The, the, the, I like how the, um, DMC by someone's voice.
Yeah.
Your left bumper and call in your machine gun.
Oh my God.
He is on controller.
All right.
Don't worry.
I know.
how to do this, too.
There you go.
I'm learning!
Where's my thing?
Oh, there he is.
Nice.
I got my stuff.
Can I steal his shit?
Alright, nice.
Look at the little baby!
Oh my god!
He's like a dad teaching his teenager's teenage son how to
play the game.
Wait, what's my mission?
I was not paying attention.
What if she was open, Mike?
No, I'm not.
I made sure I was not open, Mike.
Wait, where's our super citizen?
Who is our super citizen?
C3, right?
Oh my god, look at them.
Go.
Bug breach detected.
Don't worry, the babies will Stay in the back.
Go, Dads.
Go!
Oh, shit.
I thought someone hit me.
Oh, that's really all the eggs are.
Don't worry.
The babies will be here in the back line.
Oh, there's babies.
There's babies in the back, too.
Don't worry.
I got it.
I don't want to say...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting raped.
No!
I got fucking grounded.
Oh, no!
When your friends die, you have to call them back in with
the stratagem.
No!
Okay, please don't let him get me!
Please don't let him get me!
And then fucking...
Heal teammates, I'm not fucking healing jack shit.
We did it!
We did it guys!
Now I realize why we normally don't do open vc, like why we
don't go into voice chat.
It's so hard to like listen to my glass and do this.
Not.
He's like, bro, it's so hard to play right now while
listening to my class.
What a fucking, oh my god.
Bro,
I won't be like, what's your cool?
Why are you learning right now?
It wasn't even TV!
He's literally playing video games while in class!
It's good to just take out all these outposts and stuff.
That's it.
Holy shit.
Bro, he's- He's the teacher, bro.
He's the teacher.
I was like, I'm fucking- I'm just trying to figure out shit.
He's just like me, for real.
For real.
Guys, we're getting a free lesson while we're playing, too.
Guys, we're getting a free lesson right now, chat.
Whatever he's learning at the moment, take your notes.
Take your notes.
That's great.
That's actually great.
Look at that.
You don't have to pay tuition.
You can literally learn everything from my stream.
Is he gonna be on the test?
Doki, are there gonna be a quiz on this later?
So some of these areas there will be like supplies too that
we can pick up.
Okay.
That lettuce upgrade our...
Yeah, here we go.
Stuff later on.
That is super...
Oh my god, he's actually like teaching me!
Yeah, he is.
Am I stuck?
Um, um, you get one shot with it.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
I'm, I'm, he's like, he's actually babysitting me.
I got the super citizens.
They babysitting me.
Free college.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, thank you for the magenta super.
but thank you thank you a true patriot destroying enemies of
super before in this school tuition down payment guys thank
you for the super chat thank you all right guys what is he
learning about anyway encounter use your strategy what do i
use i don't know what to use so i'm just gonna shoot my gun
re-education i've always wanted it
oh there's a lot i'm all in here oh god there's a butt
bridge no just keep bringing all of them around don't worry
i'm helping don't do it my part oh god i hope i'm not
shooting
I got you, C3!
C3, no!
C3!
The Super Citizen!
I was hoping the other guy would do it so that...
Don't worry, I'm doing it!
I had to wait for chat to tell me!
I'm doing it!
So was that deactivated?
Guys, I'm sorry, I'm too busy trying to pay attention to
class right now!
Okay!
She did it!
Oh shit.
I did it guys!
I'm doing it!
Dude, it's been maxing by getting history and anthology
lessons.
What a true patriot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
There's the others.
The others are here now.
What is this?
Whoa!
That's a American.
I appreciate the free education today.
This is the freedom we strive for.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
This is what happens, guys.
This is true democracy.
We're getting education right now while killing insects.
What true, this is true The American dream.
You're right.
We're living the dream right now
You're so right oh my god, I think I got like shot my shield
got shot or some shit Nice you destroyed the eggs
Extractions available now
Right, I don't know what my push to talk but what's the
deal?
If I'll push the talk button, guys.
Do you guys know?
I want to ask him what he's learning.
I really want to know what he's learning right now.
Tab slot.
I'll be like, so what's your education?
What are you learning?
I'll ask him where we're not fucking dying.
Can I enroll now?
Hi, Harris.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ew.
We must know.
We must know what he's learning.
Alright, nice.
Are you learning about freedom, son?
Mission that 30 minutes remain.
Don't worry, we finished it.
We're It's just extraction now.
It's extractions now.
Welcome to Tokyo.
I already got 10 minutes of class left.
Oh, stop.
Oh, there's something weird to the left here.
I need you to like get some medals or something.
Bro, we gotta finish this before class is over!
Guys!
Bro was not learning.
Salute it.
Oh, it's good.
What the fuck?
I don't know Oh,
yeah, we hate this Because guys we need to hurry before his
class is over We Or he won't be able to people think it's
suspicious if he's not leaving his class Guess we'll just
extract here Whoa Ow I'm following C3.
We gotta do it for Super Earth and his education!
Okay, nice.
Nice, thank you C3.
Thank you, Super Citizen.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he smiled too!
He smiled at me!
Oh my god.
Look at him.
Team player.
Okay, okay.
I'll ask him later.
we're not getting like we're not trying to like you know
survive
i'm doing my part i'm doing my part where will he come from
ask him to turn up the volume no goons if you don't bruce
thank you to the stupid chat thank you
now he's asking us if we can hear him bro
Like, I was like, wait, can you guys actually?
Nice.
Oh, my God.
I just got, like, 13 kills and better.
Nice.
We're doing it.
Is there any other insects coming from this way, or is it
all from here?
I don't think we even need to shoot our guns.
Okay, I'll help this way.
Ask to compare.
I haven't asked me, like, like how's your class going on
right now like are you been like taking any notes whoa
nice extraction 26 okay i'm gonna ask in like 10 seconds is
this so calm compared to like the hurricane really oh i'm
not even playing on that hard in 10 seconds we'll ask them
see where the enemies are yeah but i'm lazy
all right here it is here it is so what class is it i'm
talking he's too embarrassed
you'll never know we'll never know what class it was
They're like, a woman!
So what class were you in?
That's a MRI.
MRI?
What?
Doing a...
Fuck.
What are you...
Which class?
This is my boss.
Bro, I didn't even know what he's learning.
Yeah, it's the sequence parameter.
and shit.
Sequence parameters?
All about the peg, fig, and sec, and coding gradients and
fucking MROs, but it's a review, so I'm like, I don't give a
shit.
He's a med student!
I'm like, I actually fucking did my homework, so I'm good.
Wait, he's a doctor?
He's an actual doctor?
Bro, oh, he's a technician.
Oh my god!
Bro, he did his homework guys guys he did his fucking
homework.
He doesn't give a fuck
This is our future doctor ready for freedom
The technician for Oh, I got I don't want this person to, if
I'm getting an MRI scan, and like, this is, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
He's a combat medic.
Guys, I can't believe it.
I basically gave you guys a free medical lecture right
there.
Okay, but if he's like, if like, the MRI, there's nothing
wrong with the MRI and he was too busy, to like know what to
do because he was playing hell divers i would be scared i
would be very scared a true patriot saving lives both as a
medical staff and kill bugs glory to super earth i mean
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you madge good to
know the medical future of super earth is in good hands
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i can't
believe it we had a real doctor with us guys holy we had a
medical combat officer i was paying attention to this class
more than he was thank you with the super chat thank you
thank you all right let's see spread democracy Let's see.
Just remembers.
Oh, my God.
How was the volume throughout all of that?
I guess it was pretty good.
Because you guys were able to listen to his class, right?
I'm pretty sure it was all right.
Because you guys could actually learn from his class.
Can I do a medium now?
Get down there and eradicate them.
Yeah, it was fine.
We heard everything.
All right, one out of four.
Learned as not.
I'm now a doctor.
I wanted to learn more from him.
You're like, Doki, why did you leave this team?
We could have learned so much.
We could have had another lecture.
There's nothing in medium, guys.
I literally can't find a medium planet.
is there a medium planet here have to complete a section to
unlock oh i need to complete a section to unlock this okay
we gotta keep fucking saving the world all right let's see
one out of four i could have had a higher education guys
this is the strat guys no no no this is the strat guys all
we have to do is um we just keep fucking queuing up until we
can find more doctors.
So, like, instead of having going to school, we can, like,
we can leech off of their education.
Taurus, think about five gifts and chips.
Thank you.
What the fuck is going?
Allied destroyer has the squadron.
Nice.
Who's our babysitter?
Wait, what?
Did they finish?
Did they fit?
Where am I?
Am I?
Wait, they kicked me out already?
They're like, oh, I'm a kid from the game.
Bro, I know I'm just a baby, but I want to be included.
I got kicked.
They clutcher kicked me.
They saw the level and was like, no, we cannot let this baby
play.
Okay, perch hatch trees.
All right.
Can't join this team.
No women.
Mission coordinates locked.
All right, here we go.
Wait, we're all babies here.
This is not good.
Guys, where's our super citizen?
Be gone, child.
Guys, this is not good.
Oh, no.
We're the baby team.
Who's gonna hold my head?
Where's our MRI tech?
Don't worry, babies.
It can't be that bad.
Oops, sorry, I keep forgetting.
This is my machine gun.
All right, let me get my machine gun.
Use your Oro Laser or Star Gem for a large group before they
notice you.
Open the mini map to see mission and side location.
All right, how do I open my mini map again?
Oh, shit, there's fall damage!
I have armor!
okay if i wear armor there should be no fall damage that
should be a rule that should be oh there it is oh my god
there it is you guys can't see it but i'm looking at it
right now i like just destroy the eggs from here oh i can i
don't even have to walk over nice
nice don't worry we are we might be babies but babies are
strong together three babies can make one super citizen
oh babies
guys we all had one job
guys what happened to our one job together we should be
strong together babies here we go Wow, the difference
between not getting killed...
It's a...
It's a huge difference.
Oh shit, why heal when I can make them heal for me?
Why use my own resources, guys?
What the fuck?
It's not suitable?
Okay.
It's that easy.
I feel like I wasted that.
Baby, it's together!
Strong!
Okay, it's alright.
It's okay.
This is fine.
I don't need ammo, guys.
Look at us go!
We're so strong!
Alright, we're gonna get rid of all of these.
It's okay, I don't need the pistol.
It's alright!
We're destroying it!
We did it, guys!
Yoink.
Alright.
I swear if I fucking get fall damage, I fucking swear.
Okay.
Now, I'm, like, so paranoid right now.
I'm actually so paranoid.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Do not worry.
Liberty is coming.
It's like those birds that like lay their eggs on the side
of the cliff and when they like grow up When they like are
at age the parents like kick them out of the nest to learn
how to fly If they don't fly they just die.
That's us right now.
That's actually us right now It's time for us to fly guys To
spread democracy we must be kicked out of the nest
Oh there's this one guy coming up okay i'm a little scared
because i'm running out of ammo i need to like call my
that's fucking right guys can we like move on it's it's okay
we don't have to kill them spread their wings of freedom
what am i playing with i'm playing with a well my last part
partner was a doctor so
He was learning about MRIs.
Okay, let's see.
Where's the resupply?
I don't have the resupply.
A quote unquote doctor.
I hope he passes his exams.
Look, he did his homework, guys.
And you guys remember what he said?
He was like, I did the homework.
Do not retreat, defend liberty at all costs.
But my ammo.
I don't have... What are we doing?
Okay.
Oh, no.
The bugs are coming.
Am I...
Alright.
I'm helping.
But he passed me Pills Hyle to help me straight your MRI.
Is that worth it?
Would you want your MRI technician to be, like, playing hell
divers i don't i need to know if you're about to get an mri
scan and your doctor is out here playing hell divers and
that is why your mri scan is getting delayed is that okay
hell yeah if it's for freedom fuck yeah it is
oh my god i keep accidentally proning okay do i have enough
for resupply god damn it I would get an MRI scan by a
Patriot.
It's for a worthy cause.
That's fucking right.
Good answer.
It was a test all along.
A fucking course you want your MRI scan by a goddamn
American of Superhurst.
Yay!
We did it.
Get a super MRI.
All right, here we go.
Where are you going, guys?
Babies!
Where are we going, babies?
Hallelujah, brothers!
Get a freedom MRI!
With extra freedom!
Why check map when I can just follow one person?
See?
I don't need to check anything.
They're doing it all for me.
need the ammo actually nice oh is it more supplies oh more
supplies I like that oh nice more reload the donation the
further cause of managed democracy thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you
Kaz, there won't be any bucks in that MRI!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I mean, oh shit!
Fucking yeah!
Fuck yeah, brothers!
Yeah, I feel bad taking that meta.
Alright, nice, okay, I just want to make sure I have enough
ammo for...
Oh, hey, it's daytime now!
Nice.
Oh.
There's, like, people behind us.
Wait, they can fly?
Oh, wait.
They're bugs.
Of course they can fly.
All right.
It's all right.
We're fine.
You have to go, like, this way.
No way.
Oh, the loot is shared?
Nice.
All right, guys.
Look.
I can look at the map, too.
Oh, it's over here.
That's where they are.
Pull it down to the machine gun.
Alright, we gotta...
We gotta go kill the big mama.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna throw it.
I already have so many nades anyway.
It's fine.
I can aim.
Oh, great.
They fly now.
Wait, bug breach?
What does that mean?
Where is it coming from?
Where's the bug breach coming from?
Oh, oh, let me reload.
Reloading.
Don't let him get the berries.
Don't touch me.
Oh, shit.
Get the ones that fly.
We got to put the ones that fly down.
Liberty.
All right, we can go up, right?
I hope I get to go to medium difficulty soon.
Here, there you go.
come.
We gotta shoot them in the head.
Okay.
Please.
The drag princess.
Nice.
Alright.
Can we go up?
Can we go up now?
Guys, we have enough violence?
I think I'm ready for medium.
Guys, it can't be that hard.
I'm going in.
I ain't afraid These guns are made for super earth Alright,
we got rid of these guys Okay, please don't shoot me Nice
Extraction available, where do we go?
Alright, we gotta go to extraction Let's go, babies!
Let's go!
Lane, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
I'm gonna miss this Babies, let's go, babies!
I'm going the wrong way and don't follow me No
Never mind Don't follow me
Alright the moment I try to lead I already went the wrong
way Like I don't know For super earth The super special
soldier.
I'm just directionally challenged.
What's this?
I got a sample.
What's it for?
Look, that's not my fault.
I just...
I'm gonna wait for them to interact.
What's this?
She's a transport.
Okay, is there anything else to loot?
It took Dooku longer to kill them than the actual weapon
art.
Hi.
Thank you for the super chat, Ty.
Thank you.
All right.
Are you guys ready?
I'm not.
Okay.
All right, we're ready.
All right, guys.
I don't think you guys were ready, but we're ready now.
You guys might have not actually been ready, but we're ready
now, guys.
Do not worry.
we don't need a super citizen we are super together baby's
never ready there's enough of us to be ready oh my god wait
if this was easy then why the fuck was that level 21 in the
easy lobby what what is he doing is it to boost his own ego
to be like look at these little babies
get rid of these guys tea chain babysitting yeah but the
supersitters it was not a friend of them like I'm pretty
sure whoa
probably farming resources we gotta farm resources what oh
there's like one of them all the way back there.
Just sniped them from all the way here.
Flexing his level, I guess.
It was nice, though.
The C3 guy.
That was just, like, being, like, picked this up.
And I was like, yeah.
Oh, and the resources are the samples I'm picking up.
Oh, I see.
I guess to, like, upgrade your chip and everything, right?
Helping newbies, I guess.
Oh my god, like true, like true, um, freedom fighters.
ART, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Go, go, Jokey Bear.
This is great to watch.
Freedom!
All right, cool.
Can you actually get, like, can you actually die from the
ship landing on you?
Is that possible?
We're super, like, a true super citizen.
Babies, we did it!
We fucking did it, babies!
Oh my god, look at us.
We fucking did it, babies.
We don't need a babysitter.
We are the babysitter.
Look at us, girl.
We even did the...
optional objective.
You can also have freedom without doom.
Can we do that?
Oh, we didn't do that.
I didn't know how to do that.
Nice.
We had to multitask with class.
Whoa!
Five stars!
Yeah!
We got five stars!
Alright, our goal today is to unlock medium.
He gets the level up and I can!
What did he do?
The squad impact.
Zero?
Wait, was it fully liberated already?
Have we colonized the planet and rid of the anti-freedom
monsters?
He did more democracy.
Oh, it's not liberated.
Liberated?
Okay, where's my ship?
I got medium, let's go!
That's all I wanted!
See you, suckers.
I got what I want, and I'm leaving you.
There we go.
We're finally...
We're finally teenagers now!
We've upgraded from babies to teenagers!
Or is it like tweens?
Are we tweens?
I feel like we're tweens now.
Guys!
From babies to tweens!
teens let's go we're pre-teens okay we gotta upgrade our
ship okay threw them away like i'm done playing with you
can't afford anything i can't i'm still too fucking broke
are you serious guys i'm still broke i i can't afford
anything why do you guys want me to go you just just want me
to okay change my ship oh wait this is
why did you guys make me look at this when you know i'm
broke oh i can purchase these wait i can wait i can okay
wait what do i purchase i can buy the yellows okay or
orbital galling barrage eoschrafing cluster bomb precision
anti-personnel supply pack what about allows you to
distribute boxes oh my god i can be like uber eats hello
uber eats here right
dokey eats hello did anyone order some dokey eats the dokey
delivery service all right which which eagle do i get eagle
cluster or i'll get the eagle cluster Eh, I can afford it.
Hey, Doki, I was at level 20 in your last match.
I didn't have a payment thing set up.
I'm a bit late on the job for this.
It was a really nice match with...
Thank you!
Oh my god!
That's a suit!
Are you the super citizen?
You were the one that was listening to the lecture with me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's him!
He was the one holding my hand to be like, pick this fucking
shield up.
no no he this one it wasn't the medical student he was the
other guy listening to the medical student he and i were
both listening he was the super citizen just listening
all right let's see uh let's see r for weapons to unlock Oh,
I want to do...
Okay, here, let's see.
Wait, you guys want to see robots.
Where's...
What is the robots?
Okay, let's see.
Eliminate Charger.
Would it say, like, robots?
Activate pumps, purge, hatcheries.
Let's see.
Press R on the ship to spend medals.
Oh, on Fortnite Battle Pass?
I can spend it on Fortnite Battle Pass?
Where will you join?
Where is it?
On the Superstore?
No.
Super credits?
Okay, war bounds.
Zero medals spent.
Do I go here?
Oh!
What is this?
Can I get better cape?
Ooh, wait.
What do I get?
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
What can I afford?
I can afford...
Okay, wait, I'm buying this.
No, it's locked!
No, but this is the best one.
I like how you guys are like, get the gun.
And I'm just like, but the finger guns, no.
You guys are like, Doki, no.
Get the gun, Doki.
I'm like, finger guns?
Finger guns?
But finger guns are so much better.
What do you mean?
The finger guns is cooler.
You don't understand.
I regret clapping too.
No, I want to equip it.
No, how do I equip?
I'm too scared.
The finger guns.
The finger guns is important.
You don't understand.
I'm so scared.
Because of that one person that was like, be careful, it
might crash your game.
So I'm always like scared now.
Okay.
What did I...
I got, like, a character.
Okay.
Oh, I can, like, have, like...
Oh, customization was...
Okay, nice.
Wait, where's the...
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Clapping.
I want...
That's good.
That's good that it's fixed.
They fixed it.
Okay.
What is...
Okay, it's randomized.
Oh, no.
I want to be brawny.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Okay.
all right let's see are we at we're a medium now we need to
liberate this planet all right we need to get what does it
say some what does it say someone was like we have to do the
robots what does it go to red area here this is not the red
oh go to red area on the other side oh okay defend Oh, is it
here?
Okay, 44%.
These are all liberated.
Go to the creek.
Where the fuck is the creek?
Oh, here!
Alright, I'm at the creek.
Where do I go?
Okay, these guys.
Maybe don't... No, okay, they're level 2.
Level 18!
Okay, level 12.
Level 4.
Level 5.
Level 20.
Where the fuck is this guy doing at level 20?
Level two.
Yeah, we're not hanging out with the babies.
We're not hanging out.
Wait.
Okay, parent launch.
Wait, am I gonna regret it?
Wait, what do you mean?
I was there for the Battle of the Creek.
Okay, maybe... Okay, wait.
Level... Okay, I'll go here.
No!
I need... I need that.
Oh my god, there's a level 23 baby!
Okay, no!
Let me in!
I need somebody to...
Oh my god, he's level 29.
Let me in.
Babysit...
No!
Please!
Please, I need somebody to babysit me, please!
Please, that's all- What the fuck?
That's all I asked for.
Let me in.
Let me in!
Level 15.
Okay.
Level 14 and level- Okay, we'll do- No!
Fine.
I'll do quick play.
But if I pick random I might be in a baby squad and I want
to be the only baby Evil thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can throw supply drop orbital strike markers on your
friends Do what you will.
Oh my god level 25 Hey guys level 50?
Whoa Hello there.
Oh, hey?
There's a level 50?
How long you've been playing this game?
Anyways, you hit to fight the robots, aren't you?
Hell yeah.
Yeah, I'm...
Alright, let's...
I don't think he's confident.
Mission preparation, a border.
I've been watching your stream for a hot while now.
Oh, my God.
Once you're ready, just happen to help out upon whatever.
Wait, how do I do this?
You're a real carry for all of us.
Oh, here you go.
There you go.
Where the fuck?
Why is there a level 50?
They exist?
Just like...
Oh my god, look at him!
Look at his gear!
shush look at this guy oh my god bro how the do you get to
the level this game came out like you know what that's okay
how we'll pay to babysit lazy thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you bro he actually got the drip bro
server long enough to be level 50 Sigma male grind set
you're not I'm not losing today boys you guys were like oh
no don't you so fucked like oh no just learn how to take
cover Learn how to take cover.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm that type of person.
Alright.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
Okay.
Wait, I'm wearing a shotgun.
What am I doing?
I'm going to get my gun.
Okay.
Don't worry guys.
You guys can...
But yeah, the robot's 8.
Alright.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
Cover me.
I'm getting my machine gun.
Don't worry.
Alright, nice.
I got my machine gun.
Wait, can they shoot back?
Wait, they can shoot back.
They can shoot back!
The reinforcements on the way.
That's fucked up That's fuck it up.
I just saw some guy explode behind me I've marked it on the
map.
They have cut it Where do we go?
Where's s4 Sure for S4 we'll follow you.
I cannot stress how much of a fucking dragoon I am don't
keep hiding.
I've been watching you for a while now Oh shit, they're
shooting If you're a dragoon If you die, if you die, let me
die, you get kicked.
A real Dragoon wouldn't let me die.
Oh, God.
There's so many things going on.
In this case, since the boss, we have four fights.
Don't worry, we're fine.
Wait, is that like a fucking Star Wars?
They'll just fucking, like, they'll just drop it on us.
This thing, they'll shoot them all down.
Is that like a fucking AT&T Walker right there?
You guys don't mind if we just wait here to do a quick, a
big quick stop.
Defender kick.
Yeah.
Defender kick!
Right now!
Also, hello, don't keep her in public squad discord.
I know you're making fun of me right now.
What the fuck?
Bro.
Wait, are you also a fucking dragon?
How the fuck did all of you You stiked me!
How the fuck?
Oh, he's just going to have with that.
Oh, my God.
Even the level 50 is a dragoon.
I learned it quickly.
Am I that easy to snipe?
Am I actually that easy to snipe?
Oh, shit.
That's right, guys.
I ain't losing any time soon.
I don't know where I'm going.
I don't I don't I don't know where I'm going
okay s4 go do the thing we are everywhere 90% of the hell
divers server it's just track boons yes really did want me
in the server did you all right nice we'll be fine do I even
need to shoot my gun the The one guy that's not Dragoon is
the one that's getting fucked over right now.
We did it!
Easiest mission of my fucking life.
Difficulty four is when the shit gets running.
Easiest... Ow!
Wait!
You can get on fire?
I don't even know.
Okay, here we go, we're good.
We're good.
I don't even have to stream open anymore.
We're not good.
Tap for map four!
I mean S4.
Where's S4?
S4 lead us.
You're the highest level.
There's the main objective.
So we gotta launch a nuke.
S4 lead us.
I'll never have to tap if I follow one person.
C4.
my god this is so easy i mean this is this is so oh my god
this is so easy uh oh there's the coach look i didn't think
i i didn't think i'd get shot you're going to want to
collect as many of those samples as possible because that's
what you want to upgrade your ship in order to get buffed
for your strategies and such why do i have to if you guys
can pick it up for me.
Wait, it's like, okay, what the Samples mean, chat, what the
Samples mean, I have to pick it up myself.
He's teaching us.
Free lesson.
What trackoons are Legion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Zach.
Okay, wait.
It's shared.
It's, okay.
I like how, like, it's shared and it's individual are both,
like, right next to it.
each other.
I like how that's next to each other.
So it's like, what is it?
Yeah, nice.
I mean, so many lessons on this server alone.
It's all shared.
Everyone gets at the end.
Oh, so I don't have to do anything.
Oh, wait, let me shoot this one guy.
nice interact I'm doing it I'm doing my part I'm doing my
part I got a supply part of terminal I did it did open the
silo I hate the creek love the what do you mean this is the
fucking easiest game of my fucking life I don't know T2 the
Oh, hey, I'm back.
It's like I never died.
Where is he?
All right.
We got to kill this guy now.
Don't know res.
Do not res him.
Do not res this man.
I'm going to steal his gun.
We don't res him.
This is my gun now.
Where is he?
If you res him, I'm killing him again.
I'm going to kill him again.
Where is he?
don't raise him we don't raise him he doesn't come back
s4 i swear to god we don't bring him back we don't bring him
back the dead don't talk no the dead don't talk
Wait, he's back!
Where is he?
The dead don't talk.
That's how you're right.
That's where you know what's good for you.
There we go.
Oh, it's so unlucky that there was some friendly fire there.
That was, that was so unlucky.
No!
Oh, fuck, wait, we might lose this!
S4, we might lose!
Oh, wait, we don't, we win.
We win.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We did it.
We're doing it!
Let me do it.
We don't need to bring them back.
S4 and I, we're gamers.
Doki never forgets, Doki never forgets.
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
What are you mean?
Wait, he struck first!
I was just...
Look, he hit me first!
Guys, this was self-defense.
This was self-defense, guys.
Oh no.
I was all about self-defending.
It's okay, S4 can carry us.
You ran in front of them, though.
Self-defense three times?
Yeah!
What are you trying to say?
Nice.
I missed it.
What do you mean?
S4, I swear to God, S4.
I-
Look at us go.
We're gamers.
We're gaming.
Wait, we get more points and we bring him back?
Oh shit, okay.
We bring him back.
I love points.
Oh.
Oh shit Oh shit Don't worry No Guys Oh fuck
Guys it's okay I'm coming back Look at that Team player Oh
shit Well that's a good thing That's a good thing I brought
people back guys oh meat pick this up and then you pick this
up hey oh no no no don't stand in front of me don't stand in
front of me all right we're good we're good we're good we're
good what is is I told you guys I can be a team player who's
gun is this a smy guy yeah this holy shit holy shit i need
reload i will need reload oh shit he's not dead anymore oh
all right we did it if you're a real dragoon you get crushed
by the chip yeah if you want to get unmuted right now get
crushed by the ship right now I will only unmute if you get
crushed by the ship.
Wait, you'll lose those points.
What do you mean?
S4 was willing to do it.
Die for me.
He's the real one.
A true mad lad.
He survived.
God bless you as for you selfless soul.
Loyal to the end.
A true freedom enthusiast.
Now we know who's really there for freedom.
Look at that.
I still got five stars.
I still got five stars after all the unfortunate accidents
of self-defense.
Nicholas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
Stay muted forever.
Hey, I said get crushed by the ship if you want to get
unmuted.
I'm doing my part.
Lo-Fi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Still a second mission to do.
This is democracy?
Hell yeah, brother.
Look at us go.
We're fucking gamers.
All right, where's my ship?
All right, see you losers.
Wait, we're done.
Zachary Sponger is truly the best of us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you leave the game real quick?
I want to play in hell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Thank you.
I did my part.
I'm doing so well.
guys.
Okay, the robots are scary.
Not gonna lie.
The robots are actually pretty scary.
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to keep playing, keep doing the
robots.
Yeah, back to the back to the bugs.
I feel like the bugs were definitely a lot safer.
the robots were a little scary that was that was not cool
that was not cool at all all right let's see what are some
levels three they're all babies where are all the adults
they're all like babies they're not even tweens okay doctor
bullet and recovery fps all right i'll get baby sat by level
by like a teenage a college student all of those lost hell
divers were clearly traders to democracy who stood in the
way of emperor president soky hey guys i'm here to oh my god
another super citizen hey guys i'm here to leech off your
mission
i'm just here to leech it off I was this those are bug
holes.
Hey guys Try it.
I'm trying guys give me a sec.
I'm trying to I'm gonna get my machine gun
Nice Sure, I can do this Go a higher difficulty and go well.
I swear Okay, guys I'll do I have to get there first Oh my
god He blew up my gun I'm coming back Hey guys Oh shit Guys
let me come up I wanna be cool just like you guys Ow Guys
There you go Hello Are we supposed to go somewhere?
Oh, we did it.
Oh my god, that's successfully leeched off of you guys.
Sponger, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, there's a level 50 chat.
The one that actually fucking...
Y'all crushed by the ship for me!
We're not cult, by the way.
We could be a religion.
For tax purposes.
No!
Shit!
Heal me.
Yeah, that's S4.
Where do we go?
Oh my god, it's Uber Eats!
He has the Uber Eats pack!
What's our church?
I don't know, you haven't filled up the forms to be legally
a church.
Oh my god.
The Democracy Deliverer.
Nabi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're definitely...
No, we're not, because we're not registered yet.
The moment.
We're not registered yet.
to be a cult for tax purposes.
Because even though you're a cult, you can still be, you
still like register as a church for like, for no taxes.
So we can't be categorized as one yet.
The word hell boy.
Hell bomb.
What's happening?
How does she know this?
Because YouTube is like, You can learn a lot from YouTube
Because there was a YouTube content creator That wanted to
legally be a church For like a day And then he like did all
Like he was All you need is like a place of worship You need
like a place of worship And you have to like get like a
church And like you have to have like a sermon
Hey guys I was a little stupid
Hey, thank you guys.
I'm happy you guys let me leech off your mission.
Thanks, everybody.
Back just a little bit.
Guys, I lost my gun.
I don't know where it went.
I'm just gonna follow you.
No, wait, where is my things?
Where did I die?
I don't even...
Yeah?
Oh, there it is.
What if I die again, though?
There you go.
I found it.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Let me...
Guys, I won't step in another mine.
I swear the guy.
Don't worry.
I'm here now.
Do not worry.
I feel bad because, like, I literally just, like...
They didn't even want me here, and I showed up.
And was like, please.
Take care of me.
They might be, like, on a fucking e-date right now, and I
just came in the third wheel.
If you think about it, high five, thank you for the five,
give the ships, thank you, thank you.
Please help.
They're like, this is the child you never wanted.
Date later.
This is war.
There is no time for e-dates.
We're here to spread democracy.
Nothing like a democracy date.
Exactly.
Oh, a laser cannon.
Can I steal this?
Alright.
Where do we go?
D1 and R2.
Do you tell they are totally in a discord together right
now?
Hey, guys.
So, like, how y'all doing?
How y'all doing?
Is your e-date going right now?
I'm sorry for like interrupting your couple time.
And like dying in the middle of your date.
So you're forced to revive me.
I'm sorry.
Democracy doesn't wait for callbacks.
Leave them alone, Doki.
What?
I'm trying to have a conversation.
They're grosses.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you They gotta spread enough democracy to earn the
freedom to date on this planet.
Take over leadership.
I've got to go AFK for four minutes.
Bro.
Oh, shit.
I have the third wheel.
Bro.
Alright, well...
Here we go.
I can't believe it!
I can't believe I was the third wheel this entire time!
I was a joke!
You ruined freedom day!
We need you to come back from your toilet break!
He can't lead us!
Oh my god.
Axeman!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I was a traitor who killed you.
Have fun spreading managed democracy into the galaxy.
Don't worry.
I'm already ruining the date right now.
Everything's going great.
It's everything I've always wanted.
He's not crying in the bathtub.
There you go.
Can we do this?
I can't believe it.
He even, like, gave leadership to his date.
What's this?
Screen is frozen.
Oh, shit, there's babies.
I like...
How is he, like, able to just aim?
KFK.
Alright, you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna...
Bye.
I'm just gonna kill these guys.
No one close to us, right?
Nice.
We're fine.
Oh.
Get out!
Your laser is too slow!
I'm just gonna...
I should kill him before.
Please!
I'm back from your toilet break!
Fine.
I'll heal myself.
Activate terminal.
Do we activate it yet?
Did you do it?
You're the leader.
Crying on the toilet from getting third wheeled.
Did you do it?
You're the leader.
I don't know what to do.
think I know what to do he assigned you to be the leader
literally useless look he assigned him to be the leader I'm
just here to shoot my gun I'm just a leecher it's their date
I'm just free-loading
hey are you doing it are you doing it r2 we did it oh my god
he's back he's back from his bathroom break look at him go
you need to help i am just here to shoot my oh my god he's
doing it look at them they can work i bet like i bet like r2
was literally like screaming was like screaming to his like
duo and be like oh my god she is not even fucking aligning
anything she's literally just standing there
he just watched me like not do anything I didn't know I was
supposed to do this.
I was not given any instructions.
Look, if there was no instructions given to me, I don't know
what to do.
I just shoot guns.
I was just waiting for D1 to come back.
They're just standing there.
I bet you, like, normally people would just do like quick
play and I'm just like reloading other people's games
shouldn't have made your lobbies public that's on you
if you didn't make your lobbies public I wouldn't be here
yeah this is basically starship troopers god so toxic
reloading What do we do?
Do we activate our stuff?
Don't want to go over there?
I'm cold, apparently.
Extreme cold.
You need to help so they can enjoy their day.
I am helping!
I'm giving them, like, the true experience of freedom.
I'm giving them the freedom experience.
Public is freedom.
interrupt your date they would have made this a private
lobby
objective guys guys i know this is like a beautiful scenery
to enjoy with your significant other but guys come on i'll
be here for a very long time if we don't complete the
objective
If you want me to leave, we gotta finish this objective,
guys.
That's fucking right.
Check your map.
I did!
And I knew the objective was over there, but I wanted them
to fucking...
I love...
I really love the Uber Eats ability.
The hostage situation.
Watch them kick you before what do you mean I was I'm
contribute I'm doing my part I hope they use your church for
the wedding blue thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you
they want you to watch their weird like that oh my god it
makes sense that's why their lobbies were public oh my god
it makes sense now Ow, they're freaks!
Ow, they're plus one!
Oh yeah, they're good.
Nice.
Oh no, not another bug breach.
Is it just that way?
Okay, it's just over there.
It's not that many.
Which is good.
Oh wait, the nuke's coming.
The nuke's coming!
Just keep going!
Just keep running!
Oh, there's some bugs in front of us!
We're fine.
Yeah!
Freedom!
Liberty!
Alright, let's go.
I'm going back there.
I'm gonna go loot.
Is there no loot here?
But why is there so much light?
How can there be so much light if there's no loot?
Okay, we're...
It's like...
Up top.
See, look at that.
I looked at my...
map guys look at that i looked at my fucking map for us not
climb up no no please i can i can horse this i can horse
this you can horse this it's possible no i can horse i can
horse this i told you it was possible i knew it was
I knew it was Skyrim horseable.
Oh, interact.
I'm gonna grab some ammo.
This?
I'm gonna do it.
Did I do it?
It just works.
Oh.
There you go.
I did it, guys.
Huh?
Guys.
Guys, someone else needs to do this.
The leader!
Do it, leader!
Dude!
I don't think that I think the leader is struggling too we
can watch him struggle together guys oh my god he did it all
right manually adjust flow rate values are you doing it okay
oh my god d1 go do your job he's a genius He's so smart!
Oh my god, he's going to the other valve now!
Oh shit, I need to help.
I need to help him.
Don't worry.
I know what my job is.
And it's not useless.
I'm not useless guys, I swear.
I'm shooting my gun I can't be useless if I'm shooting my
gun guys if you think about it good job guys thank you no it
sounded so condescending it sounded so it actually did sound
a condescending
Oh my god.
Good job, guys.
What did you ex- What do you mean?
What did you do?
Yay!
If I give us the loot, then he'll know I'm trying my best.
I did it.
Your job is sat in there and being like, Did you do it?
That's my job!
It's this way.
Okay, I know where to go, guys.
Guys, I know where to go.
Did it this way?
oh don't you say thank you to your babysitters
guys we're a team just remember that before you do anything
we're a team
wait what are they don't what are they doing do not want to
do the extraction what are they doing i think writing an
angry letter to my manager
are they trying to vote kick me before we before we leave
please no I'll give you guys supplies Do you guys like
supplies?
Oh wait, whoops.
I'll give you guys supplies guys Look
I don't have ammo.
I can't even do my one job
Nice Look see I gave him supplies he can't be mad at me
anymore
officer that's her over there all right here we go we're
coming over i'm useful where are they doing are they doing
this side objective you're in the mirror if they can take
care of me they can have a child i'm the child It's like how
like parents are like, oh, can we take care of a, can we,
should we have a kid?
And then they were like, no, we have to, we have to make
sure we, let's get a dog first so we know if it's possible.
You know, I'm that, I'm the dog.
I'm the dog test.
Like the egg test, yeah.
But like instead I'm the dog test, which is even better.
If they can take care of me, they can handle a child.
What side quest are they trying to do?
How can you...
Whoa!
Oh shit, oh shit.
No, I'm poisoned.
Oh shit.
It's okay, I'm fine.
I know you guys are so worried about me too.
I know.
I know you guys are very worried about me, guys.
Oh,
I can like fully reload this Nice Guys, what side quest are
you guys trying to do?
The extraction point is like right next to us
Okay It's fine, we're fine, we're fine Guys, the extract,
guys I don't know if you guys know this But the extraction
is available guys.
I don't know if you guys know this, but the extraction is is
very available.
Oh shit, okay.
There we go.
Guys, guys, are you guys done?
Are you guys done?
What do you guys head back to extraction yeah oh he's gonna
be on his way wait me wait which way is the traction wait
what guys wait it's like he knew already I already forgot
which way was extraction who's fucking beating me up up okay
it's like this way oh it is it's like this way
sorry guys it bounced off the hill
thanks man Thanks
Look he said sorry, I guess I guess Oh my god, he failed the
baby test guys Guys, I don't know he failed the baby test
guys I tried to run what do you I swear to god oh god oh god
Guys, I think...
I think he's done.
I think he wants this date to be over.
I don't know.
I have a feeling.
Oh shit, I killed 150 enemies!
Let's go!
I did what I've always wanted to do.
Ruin somebody's date.
He is done, baby.
See?
No.
No, stop.
Stop poking me.
There you go.
We're almost there.
Extraction is so far.
The baby bounced off the hill.
Nice.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Mom, dad, I don't know where to go home.
Thank you.
I made the break up.
Look, if I was the one that broke their marriage, then maybe
they were never compatible in the first place, okay?
I am not the main reason.
I was the breaking point.
Do I want to do it?
Good.
Yes, but also.
I was like the one that pushed them off the edge.
But it doesn't mean that I was the...
Soul cause of this
Why do you sound proud of that I didn't say I was proud of
it.
I'm just saying it's not my fault that they broke up
I was just there
Doki opening marriage counseling Steven thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Uh, T, thank you for the 20 gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, he almost killed your wife!
Guys, this isn't good.
I don't think they're gonna last any longer.
Oh my god, he actually almost naded him.
He actually almost...
Can you convince your teammates to turn off the game of
trying to fight for freedom?
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's all going wrong.
It's all going right
Everything's going wrong right now
Okay Oh, no, it's okay.
I have my shotgun
It's all right We're fine.
The ship's coming down.
It's almost freedom hours.
I just have my pistol.
All right, here we go.
We're doing it.
Stoops, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did it.
freedom
yay guys you know what I think they'll make it in the end I
feel like they're gonna make it we did it chat we did four
stars no My love, I'm the only four stars.
But why?
We did so much.
Freedom from marriage.
I don't understand.
We couldn't get five because of...
Hey!
I don't know what you're talking about.
talking if i didn't do anything wrong i didn't do anything i
can't do anything wrong if i didn't do anything if you think
about that no impact
true why can't i leave oh okay oh i was just standing behind
this man all right see you guys good luck with your marriage
I got hard difficulty because I realized that sounded weird
out of context
alright I think this was a good time I got wait oh he has
finger guns oh my god bro so is Belle and the beast now DNR
Chicho thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
alright guys I think this is a good time to call it here I
think saving a marriage is a good way to end today's stream
i hope you guys had a fun time watching um that's fun though
it's really fun just like encountering all these different
people today we encountered we encountered so many different
people today um man i had a lot of fun uh oh you guys had
fun watching too guys um that was uh that was actually like
that was honestly like really really fun i'm really glad
that i got to i got to try out hell divers uh all right guys
you guys can i gave you guys one spot in the Held Tiber
server.
Good luck.
Good luck to that one person that gets to fight for freedom.
Good luck to you.
Oh, yes.
For those who don't, before I call it here, tomorrow is
going to be streaming on Twitch for the PAL world's Twitch
rivals.
And my team is going to be for Shy Lily and um this little
indie slime called PFP I think that I don't really know uh
pronounce her name but I saw that she won a PAL world uh
competition so I invited her to join us um uh so yeah uh so
I am very excited uh to play to I just honestly I don't
really care if we get last because what I love about Twitch
rivals is that no matter what placement you get you get
automatic money
it's just no matter you know no matter what placement we
still win money in the end and like last for last place you
win like five hundred dollars so i was like what i'm fine
with that
i'm just like money's money it's yeah it's pure profit so
like I'm just here I just want to have fun I just want to
have like fun um with people oh yeah Charlotte and I were
actually supposed to we were going to collab next week so uh
we were going to collab next week but then I asked her
because I had like an extra spot and I was like oh do you
want to uh join because like she actually was was originally
trying to join power twitch rivals but like her team um they
couldn't get like a team together in time uh last minute so
then like she was actually supposed to do power world twitch
rivals but then like she had their team ended up like
dropping out at the end because they couldn't find enough
people so now i was like oh hey i still have a spot you want
to join me and she's like yeah so i was like yeah nice um uh
so yeah um and i'm going to be having a collab with shyly
next week i don't really know the details because we're
still organizing it but yeah there's a lot of fun things
that are coming up for uh next week too uh so yeah that is
what's happening for tomorrow it's a two-day event uh we
don't know what the achievements are that we're supposed to
get they're gonna give us like a list of achievements that
we're supposed to uh like like fight for like like you know
like whichever team has the most achievements by x amount of
time basically wins uh basically like uh wins or something
get like ranked and stuff um So, we're supposed to find out,
like, 15 minutes before the tournament starts.
And so, those are the rules.
And, but there were already people.
It's so funny.
I was looking at the Discord and I was, like, reading the
rules.
And there were already people that were, like, can we, like,
can we exploit?
Can we exploit and do, like, speedrun strats and stuff like
that?
And it was so funny because the staff was like, no, no, no.
No, no, no, because they're like, can we do this speed run
track?
Can we do that speed run track?
Can we do this exploit?
And then Sam's just like, no, no, no, no, no.
And I thought it was so fun.
I'm like, what the fuck?
People are already, like, training for this.
And I was like, bro, it's just Power World.
I was, yeah, I was like, holy shit.
This is like, this is so sweaty already.
crazy.
It's so competitive.
I didn't realize how competitive it's gonna be because it's
like it's just like an achievement run.
Um but yeah they're like fucking brainstorming like speed
run strats right now in the power world like twitch rivals
discord.
I was just like holy fuck I just wanted to fuck around and
have fun
but like honestly um whatever placement we get i just hope
uh to have lots of fun with uh with old and new friends uh
oh yeah also like um i'm not sure when we're gonna be uh
debut like when it's gonna be up on the store but uh we do
have the lunar new year merch uh fully done um but it's not
on the store yet because we're still like setting some stuff
up here's a little preview for everybody for the lunar new
year merch for everyone uh so that's gonna be on the merch
store uh it's gonna be soon because we're still setting
stuff up some stuff up uh but yes it's gonna there's gonna
acrylic stand some button badges some stickers the pillow uh
the red pocket envelopes and then like there's gonna be a
limited bundle this is gonna be a limited set um except for
the red pocket envelopes the button badges stickers acrylic
stand pillow is a limited run um and but the red pocket and
because like it's like themed around uh year of the dragon
so like this is themed around year of the dragon and
everything the red pocket emblems aren't but because it's
themed around your dragon there's gonna be a limited set for
like as in like a limited run not just a set but like it'll
be over the pre-orders are gonna stop at a specific month
and then um it's not gonna be brought back it's not gonna be
stay in the store forever but the red pocket emblems will
stay in the store forever um since i feel like uh since the
red pocket envelopes isn't like specific to like the year of
the dragon um but yeah i'm not sure when that's going to be
on the store but just a little update for you guys uh yeah
everybody i hope had a lot of fun hope you guys did too
anyway i'm gonna call it here because i actually have so
much work to do today uh but as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you sit for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll See you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.